[Music]
hi I'm Tom nickle and today I'm going to
talk a little bit about cloud migration
maybe you've already decided to take
your business into the cloud and you're
evaluating the right combination of
tools to make that happen or maybe your
heart isn't set on migrating just yet
and you're analyzing the benefits either
way I'm happy you're here I don't get to
do stuff like this very often now
there's no single reason that businesses
migrate but a few that come up quite a
bit tell me if any of these sound
familiar increased capacity requirements
software or hardware refresh cycles data
center contract renewals coming up the
list goes on and you should check out
our blog post to see if any of these
examples resonate personally I've got
time okay of course every company's
story is a little different and so
deciding if you're ready to migrate is
really the same as asking how will I use
the cloud once I'm there or better still
which combination of Google Cloud
storage compute networking security
databases and more can get me to the
most agile secure functionally
integrated cloud architecture phew
that was a mouthful right this can be a
big but simultaneously very fun question
to answer that's why for starters a
detailed cost-benefit analysis is so
important if you're not sure where to
start
Google's trusted partners can take stock
of your unique operational landscape
with a realistic return on investment
for every choice baked right in that way
you'll know exactly how you stand to
reduce things like operational overhead
and unused compute if you were to make
the switch to the cloud
all before you ever commit to a
migration plan next it's important to
remember that your journey to the cloud
is your journey to the cloud you'll
decide if you want to move stuff as is
first and keep it there or maybe you
modernize it after you move it or maybe
you want to modernize first then migrate
maybe you just want to rebuild a few
things altogether so where do you begin
for the workloads that you're looking to
lift and
shift you'll turn to migrate for compute
engine a tool that was purpose-built
to move physical servers or VMs into
Google compute engine it's fast and
scalable and has cool stuff like testing
right sizing and stateful rollback built
right in
want more info here's a website you may
want to check out what about workloads
you want to modernize as well for that
you'd use migrated from anthos which
lets you upgrade workloads directly into
containers in gke that means you can
take physical servers or VMs that are on
prem in GCE or other clouds and
containerize them in one fluid motion a
great way to migrate and modernize in
parallel what about data if you've got a
treasure trove of data and you don't
want to migrate it over a network you
can load it up into our transfer
appliance and ship to us directly so we
can quickly upload all that data for you
these are just three migration options
Google Offers so when it's time to
decide knowing which approach can save
you the most time and money is a
question our professional services team
and partners can help you answer keep in
mind that migrating also doesn't have to
mean entirely abandoning your on-prem
servers either in fact by definition
you'll be in a hybrid cloud state while
any migration project progresses but
with anthos we make managing hybrid and
multi cloud easier than ever before
giving you the flexibility to craft your
ideal hybrid or multi cloud even while
performing a migration in parallel learn
about the most common patterns of cloud
hybridization and multi cloud here now
if after the analysis you determine that
going fully serverless is the best path
forward you've got plenty of ways for
you to rebuild things in the cloud as
needed as well you could read about the
two main approaches and what makes them
different here ok that was a lot to
process the honest answer every digital
transformation is unique and you'll
probably end up mixing and matching
strategies so what we want you to know
is this we have the technology you need
and we're
here to help you craft the cloud and the
migration journey that makes the most
sense for you okay okay now that you've
patiently listen to me talk at you for
three minutes I'm gonna hand the
controls back the migration process can
seem daunting but the Google cloud
adoption framework is a great place to
start as is our migration center website
and with that I say bon voyage on your
migration journey and thank you so much
for taking the time to listen today
you